Thanks, Matt, for explaining that. So, the key point here is that genes provide
raw building material, but development is highly variable. It's often difficult
to draw a direct link between genes and behavior. Behavior and psychological
traits are often influenced by not only one gene, but by multiple genes working
together to produce a trait. We call these traits, polygenic. And the traits
influenced by a single gene, we call monogenic. Virtually, every psychological
trait or phenomenon, like intelligence or personality, are influenced by many
genes. Other traits, such as sexuality or metabolism, are also influenced by
multiple genes, so they're polygenic. Some monogenic traits, that are typically
influenced by a single gene are lactose intolerance, blood type or even skin
color.